un panorama desolador concreto hierro
retorcido edificios en ruinas es lo que
queda en esta ciudad turca tras el
terremoto
en este estadio más de 1500
sobrevivientes se refugian en un
campamento provisional
no puedo expresar con palabras la
experiencia que tuvimos fue aterrador y
todavía siento el dolor fui muy muy malo
muy aterrador perdí el conocimiento
después del terremoto y todavía me estoy
recuperando no recordaba mi familia ni
cómo salimos de casa
los voluntarios han llegado de países de
la región para ayudar en medio de la
crisis
hay más de 1600 personas dentro y hay
muchos bebés hay muchos recién nacidos y
estamos muy contentos de estar aquí con
ellos es muy importante para nosotros
compartir nuestra felicidad compartir
nuestros sentimientos con ellos
este hombre sobrevivió tras 187 horas
bajo los escombros y fue trasladado a un
hospital en mercine
solo recuerdo estar bajo los escombros
[Música]
Todo estaba completamente oscuro estaba
tan oscuro que ni siquiera podía ver mi
propio cuerpo
grité llamé pero no había nadie allí
el ministro de asuntos exteriores de
Turquía agradeció a la comunidad
internacional la ayuda prestada en las
labores de búsqueda y rescate
[Música]
actualmente las actividades de búsqueda
y rescatan terminado en algunos lugares
y continúan en otros estamos trabajando
duro para satisfacer las necesidades
urgentes de alojamiento las tiendas son
el refugio temporal que pueden
proporcionarse en poco tiempo
por su parte el presidente Turco receta
y verdoán quien comparó la magnitud de
los sismos con la fuerza de una bomba
atómica anunció que iniciaría la
reconstrucción de los edificios
destruidos en un plazo de un año